four astronauts have landed safely back
on earth after spending almost half
a year aboard the international space
station their spacex
dragon capsule touched down off the
coast of florida
in the first nighttime landing in over
50 years it was the first
crew mission run by a private company as
opposed to nasa
safely returned to planet earth
he's very excited these astronauts spent
almost six months in orbit at the
international space station
they splashed down in the gulf of mexico
in a rare nighttime landing
journey home took only six and a half
hours
like we said coming up in just a little
bit my hat's off to the
spacex team uh for building such a great
vehicle
and also uh the recovery operations
tonight
was was phenomenal the first time
they've done the crude vehicle at night
the mission was part of nasa's public
private partnership with elon musk's
rocket company spacex
it's being viewed as one step closer to
achieving commercial space
we're very excited to see it starting to
take off
spacex will launch another mission for
nasa later this year
and is also planning its first
all-civilian trip
to orbit all happy reunions with your
families and loved ones
and thanks again for flying spacex